the first hint of potential trouble
between Patrick Peterson and the
Cardinals may have come from this
Instagram post a photo of Patrick
Peterson with a bunch of former
Cardinals defensive backs including
Tyrann Mathieu now with the Chiefs said
Peterson in the caption to the photo my
boys told me to watch out for the snakes
in the long grass now against that
background former NFL receiver Antonio
Bryant who has been insisting the
Cardinals won't take calamari with first
overall pick in the draft Bryant went to
Twitter to say Patrick Peterson to the
Chiefs that happened yesterday morning
chris around 11:30 a.m. Eastern or there
abouts that sparked me to make some
phone calls to figure out if indeed
Patrick Peterson had been traded to the
Chiefs I quickly learned there hadn't
even been any dialogue between the
Chiefs and the Cardinals for Patrick
Peterson but I quickly became aware that
something was going on with Patrick
Peterson they put the fire out quickly
Kent summers of the Arizona Republic
later reported that someone in Cardinals
management said something to Peterson
that quote pissed him off and quote but
ultimately it's not a big enough of a
deal for Peterson to demand a trade so
that's where we are it was a weird 15
minutes or so because I had a source who
created the distinct impression
something was up
15 minutes later everything was fine so
apparently whoever pissed off Patrick
Peterson properly genuflected kissed the
ring did whatever to make Patrick
Peterson not as upset as he was but it's
still something that I think bears
watching yeah definitely I mean Patrick
well I mean come on there was rumors
last year about Patrick Peterson to the
Kansas City Chiefs then of course there
was him coming out saying you know he'd
like to be traded or maybe play play for
another football team he's still one of
the best corners in football I mean he
is a guy that you can put on an island
against the best receivers in the game
and you can go okay I feel good there we
got Patrick Peterson over there to cover
whatever receiver it is he is capable of
doing it what I mean I'm what I'm I
would love to be a fly on the wall you
know in these instances you know at
least in in my history and knowledge I
mean either he was challenged as a
player and didn't like that I mean that
would be the FIR
thing that comes to mind maybe the the
guy said something about his play that
pissed him off or maybe said he wasn't
one of the best corners in football or
maybe said somebody else was better than
him that would be the first thing that
would come to my head with these type of
situations after that you know I don't
know what else can be said that could
really make a player go off other than
just being personally disrespected in a
way where you feel like you're not
appreciated so it has to be something
along those lines and this I think this
is something to watch for this is 3rd
4th time there's a little scuffle
between these two in the last year to
where I would not be shocked at some
point this offseason the Patrick
Peterson ends up somewhere else well my
theory and I guess it's more like a
hypothesis but it all makes sense given
the context wouldn't surprise me if
Patrick Peterson said to someone from
management what he thinks they should do
with the number one overall pick baby
and the response may have been along the
lines of just worry about yourself
issues to be concerned with right or
something along those lines and he still
may be salty that they fired Steve
Wilkes after only one season is the head
coach because Peterson's a guy who was
all in with Steve look so there could it
just it's one of those things where if
there's already some resentment if
there's already some hesitation some
fraying of the relationship it doesn't
take much to push it over the edge and I
wouldn't be surprised if some of the
guys who view themselves as cornerstone
members of the team think that they have
license to tell Steve Kim or anyone else
in management what they think they
should do with that first overall pick
yeah whatever it was it's here and it's
gone at least for now but I agree with
you it's something we should keep an eye
on keep an eye on for sure you know and
there's other things that make me just
think it's a little weird over there
okay hey they love tyrone matthew they
loved him right in arizona i mean they
love the honey badger they they you know
really gave him his chance after you
know it hurts his knee they bought in on
him they wanted to keep him when he was
a free agent two years ago mataira
Matthew decided he wanted a new change
so you know for me for a guy like Tyrann
Mathieu to not want to stay there when
the team really wanted him and he had a
best friend in Patrick Peterson and they
show that they were vested him and and
sounds like we're willing to pay him
pretty good money and he
liked his prospects at Houston more you
know tells me that something wasn't
comfortable there for time around
Matthew either to where he liked being
in that organization and he wanted to
move on so I don't know what it is and
obviously our man Patrick Peterson is
kind of saying something like that with
his snakes in the grass type of
Instagram post and even though Antonio
Bryant was wrong I mean somebody told
him or somebody led him to believe
Patrick Peterson is going to the Chiefs
or maybe wants to go to the Chiefs and
maybe that's how it got all twisted hey
if they're gonna treat me like this they
should just trade me to the Chiefs and
the next thing you know Antonio Bryant
runs with this idea that he's already
been traded to the Chiefs but that may
be where he wants to go where he'd be
reunited with Tyron Matt
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports